belle photo hein c'est un beau spécimen
donc elle vous plaît tant mieux si vous
voulez s'il vous plaît c'est de quoi
donner des complexes aux hommes non
Christophe de ministre il paraît d'après
un sondage que vous êtes le joueur rugby
préféré des Français la coqueluche de
ces dames alors c'est pour séduire votre
public féminin que vous publiez les
bleus à l'âme aux éditions du
Cherche-Midi avec une une couverture
assez accrocheuse pour le moins
parce que maintenant vous avez décidé de
vous montrer toujours des vêtus c'est
devenu une seconde nature sauf que c'est
une posture on a pas droit à ça ce soir
mais quand on fait un livre quelque part
on essaie de se mettre à nu donc la
photo était trop bien trouvé elle avait
été faite quelques temps puis la Coupe
du monde de rugby 2017 est en France
c'est un événement important ça sera
certainement un de mes derniers gros
événements sous le maillot tricolore
donc voilà vous dites que c'est aussi le
moment de le vendre pendant que vous
êtes en haut de la fiche je sais pas si
c'est réellement quand on écrit un livre
si on s'attend des grosses retombées
financières du moins pas du tout c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas très très
important sincèrement on le fait plus
pour assumer quelques bleus à l'âme et
pour assumer quelques pensées ou pour
dire les vérités à certaines personnes
je crois que c'est ça le plus important
avant de penser à gagner des sous
contrairement à vous désolé mais voilà
c'est avant tout par rapport à soi-même
par rapport aux gens qui ont été
important dans notre vie et essayer de
raconter l'histoire et de dire
réellement comme elle a été alors tout
de suite je vous propose un retour sur
votre carrière en compagnie de votre
mère qui est votre première femme
regarde
le 31 octobre 1999 la vie de Christophe
Dominici bascule grâce à la magie d'une
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde remportée
face au monstre néo-zélandais ce jour-là
c'est David contre Goliath Christophe
dominicien 1m73 pour 80 kg et le héros
de toute la France
mes à peine un an plus tard en novembre
2000 il craque sombre dans la dépression
et fait une cure de sommeil de 3
semaines cela s'est coté Nicole sa mère
est montée de Toulon à Paris pour le
soutenir Christophe était au plus mal
bien entendu j'ai ressenti beaucoup de
peine parce que bon vous avez peur pour
lui surtout qu'il faisait
semblant finalement d'être heureux alors
qu'il était malheureux
[Musique]
de souffler à ce moment-là en novembre
2000 et voilà quoi c'est que j'avais
oublié j'étais obligé de me recadrer de
leur donner naissance et un but à ce que
je faisais quoi Christophe va très vite
retrouver un sens à sa vie c'est même
après cette période de déprime que sa
carrière atteint des sommets des
trophées précieusement conservés par sa
famille
la somme promis son premier ballon de
l'équipe de France
en Angleterre
c'est mon musée à moi voilà
ça vierge c'est bougies
et Christophe avant de commencer à
marcher à tout
[Rires]
joueur grand match aujourd'hui
Christophe Dominici se met à nu dans un
livre où il raconte son parcours ses
bleus à l'âme et même sa vie sexuelle il
nous offre aussi chaque année une autre
partie de lui-même dans le fameux
calendrier des Dieux du stade des photos
osées réalisées avec ses coéquipiers et
qui ont pour le moins surpris la mère de
cet homme à femme
j'ai pas été surprise de certains propos
de Christophe parce que je suis un peu
ça confidence et donc il me racontait
ses aventures maintenant le calendrier
cette année même un peu choquée pour la
bonne raison que c'est de plus en plus
dénudé on arrive à avoir quand même
le sexe de la personne
de certains Christophe il est bien
provoqué je pense que ça sera peut-être
la dernière année qui l'osera Pascal
alors je sais plus comment il va se
montrer
voilà belle photo
alors non mais sérieusement Oui mais ou
alors des envies
oui oui de toute façon c'est un
calendrier qui plaît aux hommes comme
aux femmes et d'ailleurs vous en
profitez pour tendre le coup aussi aux
rumeurs vous revenez sur sur les rumeurs
tout ce que vous avez tous exposés à des
moments quand on est devant la scène
quand on exposait quand on est
médiatique on a tous à des moments donné
entendu ou lu des choses qui sont pas
forcément plaisir donc homosexualité
homosexualité faut dire que c'est faut
dire que le calendrier est tellement
tendance aussi
c'est joli calendrier et que on me dit
on me traite dans le sujet comme ma
femme donc alors abandonné quand on
montre des hommes un petit peu nus avec
des muscles forcément on est sur la
tangente quoi qu'on puisse dire
maintenant je crois que rentrer dans les
mœurs ça fait 7 ans qu'on le fait les
premières années il était il était pas
au temps accepté autant toléré et
pourtant que c'était beaucoup plus chaud
c'est pour ça qu'il commence à rentrer
il est beaucoup moins tabou que qu'avant
beaucoup moins tabou ce qui est très
joli de dans ce que dit votre mère dans
le dans le reportage qu'on vient de voir
c'est qu'elle a été beaucoup plus
finalement choqué par cette photo par
vous nu dans les calendriers de voir son
fils nu que par ce livre ou pourtant
vraiment vous dévoilez beaucoup de
choses il y a même des moments assez
chaud quand même de génération quoi
qu'on puisse dire ma mère elle est pas
habituée à voir ça donc forcément quand
elle a vu la première fois le calendrier
elle m'a dit oh là là on voit c'est pas
ce photo là déjà et ça c'est les
dernières photos donc forcément je peux
comprendre un peu coupé vous avez vu
qu'on a un peu raboté parce que on s'est
dit qu'on prime on ne pouvait pas
descendre plus bas c'est vous qui
choisissez vos photos on choisit en
fonction des poses parce qu'il y a des
postes qui sont un peu plus provoquant
provoquant on va dire il y a des pauses
qui voilà qui on a peut-être un peu plus
interprétation peut-être différente on
essaie de c'est vrai de toucher aussi
quelque part un large public on va pas
200 000 calendriers parce que à un
moment donné voilà les photos les photos
sont belles c'est quand même beaucoup de
ventes des belles ventes
chaque année à différents caritatives on
avait toujours profité les gens quoi
leur parlons de vous de votre de votre
vie amoureuse puisque vous aussi vous
vous en parlez personne n'y échappe
autour de la table j'ai relevé une
phrase moi qui m'a vraiment beaucoup
fait rire puisque vous allez loin dans
la confidence de l'amour quand même même
si effectivement il y a tout votre vie
mais vous parlez aussi de votre vie
sexuelle et vous dites quand je fais
l'amour avec une femme je donne je
câline je suis très fleur bleue amoureux
fou de l'amour et des belles femmes je
me retrouve comme sur un terrain de
rugby je suis moi libre et léger
alors je me suis dit je me retrouve
comme sur un terrain de Ruby je me suis
dit mais dans quel état vous en sortez
après l'acte à vous et votre copine quel
chantier
elle est lui dans quel état c'était pour
eux pour dire parce que parce que
j'essaie d'expliquer du moins j'essaye
c'est pour sourire d'expliquer beaucoup
de choses c'est pour dire que quelques
fois quand on fait l'amour n'oublie tout
et on oublie nos soucis nos problèmes
nos états d'âme et ça devient très
facile c'est ce que vous dites
d'ailleurs il y a des similitudes entre
faire l'amour et jouer au rugby ce sont
les seuls moments où tout est facile
pour moi oui bien sûr pouvoir jouer
devant 80 000 personnes je crois que
c'est un privilège quelque part et à un
moment donné on donne on donne on donne
on essaie de faire du spectacle on
essaie que les gens prennent du plaisir
donc on a quand même un petit peu de
responsabilité quoi qu'on puisse dire et
quand on fait l'amour à une femme
quelque part on a un petit peu l'homme
un petit peu de responsabilité quoi
qu'on puisse dire
c'est une réflexion un peu machiste
l'homme a une certaine responsabilité la
femme aussi mais aussi mais mais c'est
vrai que mon éducation fait que
peut-être dans mes propos on peut croire
que je suis peut-être un peu machiste
quelque part au-delà que j'ai des
origines Corse donc on a quand même une
éducation et quelque part on est quand
même un petit peu macho mais je me suis
pas beaucoup sincèrement sincèrement
Nadine
vraiment bon bah d'abord parce qu'il est
Corse c'est que j'aime beaucoup l'écorce
et qu'en plus ne me dites pas ne me
dites pas parce que c'est le c'est le
schéma de l'homme classique machiste et
bien oui Mireille
non ce n'est pas vrai mais si vous savez
que je suis marié un Corse à je ne
savais pas
voyez je vous fais une confidence on est
deux à aimer ce genre d'homme parce que
moi je n'ai pas dit qu'il était machiste
oh écoutez je l'ai rencontré une fois et
alors et c'était c'est un homme je suis
un navré pour vous mais c'est un homme
bah non c'est un homme oui oui
c'est un homme est-ce que Monsieur en
régie peut nous remettre la photo
elle vous plaît bien Tristan cette photo
oui non parce que les petits bonhommes
qui marchent c'est bien mais c'était pas
mal aussi la photo c'est vrai tout à
coup notre ambiance
justement pour continuer à vous faire
sourire je racontais qu'un soir votre
femme voulait vous suivre justement dans
une troisième mi-temps après un match
vous n'avez pas que je vais faire des
ennemis là vous n'avez pas accepté
qu'elle ne vienne donc tes amis
peut-être
j'ai pas accepté mais c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment entre
copain pour parler un petit peu de
psychologie
mon ex-femme avait pris la place de ma
sœur dans ma tête donc pour parler un
petit peu psychologie et on n'aime pas
que ça sort ou quelque part sa mère nous
suit et viennent avec nous notre
émission quand j'ai rencontré mon
ex-femme je sortais de de
du décès de ma sœur je l'ai rencontré
peu de temps après elle m'a redonné
envie de de vivre et de me reprocher
dans une vie et forcément il y a eu de
la passion il y a eu beaucoup de choses
et j'ai mis beaucoup d'espoir à travers
elle et j'ai occulté complètement
pendant 10 ans que j'avais une sœur j'ai
pas voulu en parler on me demandait je
suis fils unique et quand il y a eu la
séparation avec mon ex-femme c'est comme
si je perdais une deuxième fois ma sœur
et j'ai très mal vécu j'avais pas fait
le deuil de ma sœur et il a fallu que je
fasse le deuil de mon ex-femme
je fasse le deuil de mon ex-femme et le
deuil
de ma soeur en même temps donc il a
fallu que j'assume tout ça et il fallait
que je sois bon rugby il fallait que
j'explique pourquoi donc c'était quand
même beaucoup de choses beaucoup de gens
on peut vraiment comme on dit craquer
vis-à-vis de soi ou exercer la violence
sur l'autre mais
quand ça nous échappe on peut être
violent avec avec son partenaire avec
son partenaire avec sa femme avec ses
parents quand on peut être violent dans
les mots violents dans les gestes c'est
pour dire on existe on est là regardez
nous on est là ne partez pas nous
laisser pas on veut encore vivre on va
encore avancer on veut comprendre aussi
c'est vraiment l'amitié la solidarité
même la violence du rugby qui vous a
empêché de basculer mais j'ai eu des
Bleus corps c'est beaucoup plus facile à
soigner malgré des factures mal des
opérations si on les comprend quand on a
des bleus à l'âme
c'est des bons à la tête malheureusement
les comprend pas toujours on met
beaucoup plus de temps les expliquer
donc on va avoir des psy on essaie
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi ils
arrivaient ça on essaie de trouver une
explication quand on se casse le poignet
on va voir un médecin nous dit voilà on
répare et puis c'est facile ça ira mieux
dans un mois et demi mais quand on est
mal dans sa peau quand on a du mal à
gérer quand on vit des angoisses quand
on a des moments de doute il faut
trouver très vite la solution très vite
la solution parce que le monde
malheureusement nous attend pas donc
forcément je vais un moment des moments
très difficiles le regard des autres
j'étais pas habitué à être jugé parce
que quand j'ai eu ma déprime et que
j'étais plus un mot de l'affiche quoi
qu'on puisse dire le regard des gens ils
changent d'ailleurs vous dites que cette
longue déprime qui était quand même
costaud finalement vous sert elle me
sert parce que ça a été complètement
positif pour vous je trouve que l'être
humain il réagit que quand il est
confronté à des échecs et à des moments
douloureux c'est là où il se remet
malheureusement en question c'est pas
dans le positif il se revendique si on
sait quand il est confronté au négatif
et dans la douleur et moi je me suis
remet en question malheureusement par la
séparation et mon ex-femme le décès est
toutes ses épreuves m'ont fait grandir
et les rencontres que j'ai faites tout
au long de ma vie m'ont permises de
faire des fondations un peu plus solides
je vois toutes les femmes et l'autre
homme de la table vous écoutez mais très
attentivement parce que c'est tout chaud
magnifique en plus c'est genre
magnifique sur un terrain c'est
incroyable la hargne la rapidité puis ce
regard quand il vient de marquer c'est
rare les joueurs aussi aussi beau quoi
[Rires]
à vous et même mettre en avant comme ça
ça fragilité sa vulnérabilité qui
l'assume qu'il expose qu'il a analysé
qui nous l'offre quelque part c'est très
touchant très touchant et votre livre
touche aussi les hommes penser lunettes
oui évidemment ça va toucher les hommes
parce que Christophe de ministre est
devenu un modèle il le disait tout à
l'heure au départ c'est pas vraiment le
cas il est plutôt petit il est plutôt
1m73 c'est pas c'est pas un mètre 80
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
a fait bouger les les lignes moi ce qui
m'intéresse mais pas en tant qu'homme
parce que je trouve intéressant c'est
les livres qui font bouger les
frontières pas ceux qui les perpétuent
et qui bétonnent les frontières ceux qui
font bouger qui vous émeubles vous voyez
qui vous qui font que vous êtes
différent quand vous en sortez et à mon
sens là oui d'ailleurs quelque chose
d'intéressant parce que il inverse la
perspective tout à coup vous dites moi
aussi
je vais peut-être pouvoir alors que je
sais pas gagner au départ c'est
franchement pas gagné et en plus je me
chope des coups de blues qui se termine
en dépression on veut plus de moi parce
que ce qui dit pas et qui est dans le
bouquin il y a il raconte bien la façon
dont tu as un moment il est Ricard
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut plus lui en
équipe de France c'est pas gagné non
plus de changer de club et irait c'est
une résurrection c'est un phénix regarde
et puis non seulement c'est un phénix
mais c'est un phénix qui va marquer et
qui va identifier le 15 de France je
crois qu'il y a des livres qui sont
intéressants précisément parce que tout
à coup ils vous raconte un destin
et un destin c'est fatalement fait de
souffrance de douleur de moments on se
casse la figure on tente de remonter où
on se recasse la figure et où malgré
cela
on marque les seuls pour ne rien manquer
sur ma chaîne Ina Mireille Dumas
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche
[Musique]